hello everyone and welcome to a really
exciting game that's not even a game
it's more of an
analysis that was sent to me by a
gentleman named
and he said that he found a spectacular
move while preparing for this very
certain line
now if this is something that you play
online or maybe in some blitz games
this will come in very handy as i'm sure
you can win a lot of games using this
and if not you might even consider
starting playing this
as it's uh well it's just one of those
moves that you want to show
everyone to your of course friend and to
your friends at the bar in the library
and
uh it's just uh uh well it's just
amazing and here we're
i'm again using uh not one hoodie guy
but two hoodie guys and it's not
even because we don't know who the
player is this is not a game
so there are no players i'm just wearing
a hoodie because i enjoy them
so without further ado let's check out
this interesting position
and uh while suggesting this noroshkov
uh mentioned
that this rook makes the rook from the
steinitz versus bardolieben
uh look like a coward now whether this
is true or not uh i will let you guys
decide and also
if you haven't seen uh that game uh
stunning versus uh
body laben i will put a link to it in
the description below first thing you
will see so you can check that out as
well
uh really insane if you still haven't
seen it so let's see what
what's happening here so e4 black
replies with e5
and now bishop to c4 the bishop's
opening
we have knight to f6 uh and now d4
striking in the center right away this
is the ponciani gambit
and now black has a few choices black
can either
ignore this which is not all that great
if something like knight to c6 would
immediately
advance our opponent to d5 you can
capture on d4 or you could capture
knight captures an e4 but knight
captures on e4
isn't all that impressive because we
just capture on e5
and now all of these squares are now
covered and
the knight isn't looking all that great
on e4
and you could even run into a lot of
problems for example if bishop c5 you go
after the f2 pawn
just queen d5 and white wins there's the
threat of checkmate also the
knight is hanging and this doesn't help
if bishop captures just king f1
still this is checkmate and the the
knight is hanging here so
this is just game over you have to
defend against checkmate then we pick up
the piece and it's game over
so instead after this d4 move black will
not go for
knight captures and e4 rather black will
capture on d4
and now we give up yet another pawn so
knight f3
uh black captures it and now we capture
the pawn back with queen captures on d4
attacking the knight knight goes back
knight f6 and now
knight to c3 so uh white gives up a pawn
but
he does have some very rapid development
the knights are already out the queen is
centralized nd for bishop
slicing all the way uh to f7
uh so black can't really com a white
can't really complain here
we have knights the c6 uh attacking the
queen and
queen the h4 now we have bishop to e7
and now bishop to g5 both players castle
now
so castles castles ended now uh this
position has been reached before uh some
some of the known moves are d6 this is a
new move h6 this is a known move
but the move that we are discussing here
is the the move that
was suggested to me via email and that
is knight to e8 and this is uh in some
lines even the strongest continuation by
the engine
uh the black offers a trade of the dark
square bishops
uh and he wants to trade down survive
the attack and enjoy his extra pawn but
there is a problem here here white goes
to rook
h to e1 so what do you play here well
black says
i don't really mind this is really all i
ever wanted so bishop captures on g5
with check
knight captures on g5 and this is now
where the magic happens here
black has only one good move and it's uh
it's not an easy move to make because
white is threatening checkmate and you
kind of want to prevent that so here
h6 is the move you have to play and
after h6
white has a variety of options uh the
most uh
interesting one seeming uh seemingly f4
uh now offers the knight and you don't
really want to capture this if you
capture this then just spawn captures
and you don't really have a good defense
here uh
whatever you play this rook can very
easily come into the attack we're gonna
check checkmate the black king without
much problems so what you would have to
do after f4
is play something like d6 and then the
game continues with something like queen
h5 a nice triple attack on the f7 pawn
knight to f6 attacking the queen and
here we just trade
knight captures on f7 knight captures on
h5
knight captures on d8 with a discovered
check
king to h8 and now knight captures on c6
b
captures and now let's say g3 defending
our f4 pawn and we would have this end
game where
the material is equal however white's
pawn structure is intact
and he will uh well he only has two pawn
islands black has
three pawn islands and also black has a
double c pawn
so white will enjoy the advantage for
for the rest of the game
uh this is the best uh that black could
hope for
however for the purposes of this video
black defense check made not by h6 but
rather with knight to f6
so uh pretty weird but you know if it
works
why not the problem is it doesn't work
so feel free to pause the video here
and try to find the winning move for
white the incredible winning move for
white
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on
spotting that it is indeed the move from
the thumbnail i'm also checking if you
guys even watch the positions from the
thumbnail
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's rook to e8 and rook
the e8 is the move
that shows how brave this rook is
because this rook cannot be captured but
uh you don't really have an option you
have to capture it
uh well i will return to this move as it
is very interesting now you could also
win with bishop captures on f7 but it's
super complicated and well you have to
really really
work for your meal for example rook
captures on f7 now you go
knight d5 of course the knight cannot be
captured because the knight has to keep
an eye on the h7
pawn so here we would see something like
h6
and then of course knight captures on f7
attacks the queen
and uh you don't really well you don't
really have all that much uh you can do
here king captures an f7
now king queen to c4 threatening nasty
discoveries so king of f8 you have to
get out of the way and now
rook to d3 and here while this is
most likely winning for white it would
be well you would have to
really really struggle to to prove that
for example d6 you're gonna go rook f3
now you put a lot of pressure on this uh
knight here and after something like
knights the e5 attacking both the rook
and the queen now you have to give up
the rook captures captures
and now knight captures on f6 finally g
captures and rook g3
and you will now be able to to get a
winning advantage here
however we can do this uh much more
quickly by just playing rook to e8 so
congratulations once again to everyone
who found this
and now the rook uh can be captured by
the rook by the knight and
by the queen so can who can capture the
rook let's try capturing with the knight
we already said that if the knight moves
just queen captures an h7 is checkmate
so obviously not with the knight
can we capture with something else if we
capture with the queen
the problem is knight to d5 taking away
the defender
of the h7 pawn so of course if the
knight moves queen captures is again
checkmate
so here we would have to play h6 but now
now we play
knight captures on f6 g captures and now
knight to e4 and there is no defense
against knight f6 if this either wins
the queen
or if the queen moves doesn't really
matter where let's say queen e5
now we again find rook to d3 the rook is
now coming
to help with the attack and there's well
there is really nothing you can do here
if d5 trying to open up the light square
bishop a little bit
uh doesn't help at all just knight
captures on f6 king h8
and now queen captures here will be
checkmate or in any of the other lines
black has to part with his queen
so let's return to this position knight
cannot capture queen cannot capture so
let's see what happens if rook captures
this is the move that was played in our
hypothetical game so here
what we would see is actually knight
captures on f7 this is just
amazing now the queen is being
threatened and the queen is lost
there's no way to save the queen because
if the queen moves
then we get knight to g5 a nice check
from the bishop
king to h8 and now again knights to d5
this is the move that always wins for us
in all of the lines because we just uh
remove uh remove the defender of this
h7 pawn so here again not much you can
do if queen to f8 uh
just getting the queen out of the way
doesn't really help because
knight captures on f6 and again now
we've removed the defender if you
capture this is just
checkmate and if you don't uh again not
much to be done here if h6 then we're
just gonna play
knight to f7 with check and now all of
these squares are covered by the two
knights so black has no options black
must capture the knight
so after queen captures on f7 bishop
captures uh would be played and now
again
yeah it's just too much material for
white of course if this is captured
then this is again mate in one there's
nowhere for for the black king to go to
so really really exciting stuff uh i
still haven't tried it
uh uh but i will uh today when i'll be
playing some bullet unleaches i'll
probably
play some bishop c4 and d4 and see how
it goes so maybe i can get some
victories uh
hopefully none of the people there watch
my videos and i can you know sneak this
in
uh but it is very very interesting just
uh you know everything is everything's
been played before and whoever plays
this sponsyani opening and
this gambit uh will probably find
himself in positions like these
but then the question is whether uh in
this position black will will go 98 or
maybe black will go
uh for for some of the other moves like
that we've mentioned d6
h6 or or whatever but here you can just
immediately grab this
and you know the game basically plays
itself for quicker time formats is
it's just just an awesome game uh but
yeah here this
rook rook the e8 move really really an
impressive one
and for those of you who still haven't
seen ashtonites versus bottled label and
do check it out at the first link in the
description below
and tell me which rook is braver is this
rook braver
for his rook the e8 or is steins rook's
braver
i don't know it's uh you know uh it's
hard to say but
uh i myself preferred the steinitz one
because
he did not deliver a single blow he
delivered blow by blow by blow by blow
us i mean it was uh
just insane uh uh that's the game or
rather uh
hypothetical game that never actually
happened or or maybe it did somewhere we
just don't know
so hope you guys enjoyed that and i've
also received one email
uh from a subscriber that's uh currently
working uh
on board a merchant vessel working
working as an electrician
and he said that he has a very cheap
plastic chess board
in his room now let me just load it this
is the the chess board in his room
and he says that uh while when whenever
he leaves the room he finds that someone
played a move on the board and then he
plays it and
again when he returns someone finds uh
he finds a different position and here
we have some sort of a
i don't know what's that like like a
rule opens berlin defense evans gambit
crossover
uh something uh could be a very
interesting game
uh he will be he will send us the entire
game after he finishes with
the game with this mysterious person he
has no idea who it is
but he has his suspicion so we'll you
know we'll we'll see what happens but
very exciting stuff
uh i mean you leave your room and you
know pieces move on your board very nice
but yeah that's it i hope you guys enjoy
that uh looking forward to hearing what
happens with
with this mystery game uh i would like
to thank uh thomas johnson
benjamin davidson uh toby fleming
sebastian adam and
jacob zusman for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching
and i will see you soon uh continuing
the coverage of the morphe saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day